und mir zugeschaltet ist jetzt die ko
verfügt auf denen die ukrainischen
unterstützt als tschechien weiß dass die
vorsitzende der spd saskia esken guten
soldatinnen soldaten auch gelernt haben
ersatzlieferung bekommen werden auch
das richtig verstanden frau erst gegen
morgen frau ist guten ringer-bundes
tschechien muss ja sein seine armee
deutschland hat gar keine schweren
jetzt hat sie also begonnen offenbar wir
waffen die das land liefern könnte
ausgestattet wissen sowie die bundeswehr
haben es gerade berichtet die erwartete
eben auch einen grundbestand an waffen
deshalb will sich deutschland nun darum
russische großoffensive im osten der
kümmern auf andere art und weise schwere
behalten muss um auch selbst fähig zur
ukraine ändert dass frau esken die
waffen zu liefern die bundeswehr verfügt
haltung des bundeskanzlers keine
landesverteidigung zu sein
über keine weiterhin frei verfügbaren
schweren waffen an die ukraine zu
damit darf ich kollaps schulz ist mit
liefern
waffen abgegeben werden können deswegen
man muss ja angesichts dieses jetzt
herrn zielinski ständig im gespräch
muss jetzt die industrien müssen wie
begonnenen großangriffs noch mal
dazu muss ja nicht nach kiew reisen
gesagt auch mögliche andere lieferungen
deutlich sagen wladimir putin hat der
sondern die telefonieren und schalten
ukraine mit einem verbrecherischen und
möglich gemacht werden die
bundesregierung ist dabei diese
und sind im dauernden austausch es ist
völkerrechtswidrigen angriffskrieg
überzogen und der will offenkundig die
möglichkeiten auszuloten jeden tag und
auch dringend notwendig denn man muss
ukraine zerstören er will das
wird auch weiterhin das wie gesagt in
immer wieder auf den neuesten auf dem
ukrainische volk vernichten und die
enger abstimmung mit den europäischen
neuesten stand sein aber eben es müssen
partnern und auch mit den
bundesregierung olaf scholz und die
transatlantischen partnern tun die
auch immer wieder gespräche geführt
ampel koalition stehen fest an der seite
werden mit den europäischen partnern mit
europäischen partner liefern ja bereits
der ukraine und des ukrainischen volkes
den transatlantischen partnern mit den
jetzt gerade das neue paket aus den usa
und deswegen haben wir von anfang an
usa warum erklärt der bundeskanzler
da sind hubschrauber und haubitzen dabei
schon zu beginn des angriffskrieges mit
seine politik nicht besser
der bundeskanzler hat in der
waffenlieferungen reagiert mit harten
sie haben von ausloten gesprächen das
hört sich unglaublich lang an die
vergangenheit seine politik erklärt und
sanktionen reagiert die immer wieder mit
ukraine hat ja keine zeit also wie lange
es wird auch weiterhin tun das ist seine
den partnern in der europäischen union
aufgabe auch orientierung und auch
würde das dauern wenn sie sagen es geht
an den transatlantischen bündnis
um die industrie deutschland könnte
richtung zu weisen in der regierung aber
abgesprochen werden oder schuld wird
dafür sorgen schwere waffen zu liefern
auch heute wieder diese gespräche führen
vor allem auch an die bevölkerung das
das hört sich nach wochen nicht monaten
die notwendig sind um dann die nächsten
wird auch weiterhin tun es ist aber auch
an nein wir beginnen und olaf schulz
aufgabe natürlich alle partner in der
schritte zu beraten so richtig weiß wie
beginnt ja diese gespräche nicht heute
haben sie die frage nicht beantwortet
sondern diese gespräche werden schon
koalition der an der ampel ministerinnen
ich gehe davon aus dass es die haltung
andauernd geführt es werden auch schon
nicht ändert das heißt die
und minister und natürlich auch der
bundesregierung will weiter keine
in den letzten wochen sind auch schon
parteien deswegen bin ich heute morgen
schweren waffen an die ukraine liefern
bei ihm
waffen geliefert worden auch darüber
und ja wir haben ihnen einige fragen
warum nicht die bundesregierung hat es
hinaus weist die bundeswehr im stande
gestellt vielen dank frau erst die spd
ist zu liefern insofern wir sind
bereits ermöglicht das schwere waffen an
chorvorsitzende für dieses interview
beständig daran die und die ukraine in
sehr gerne
die ukraine geliefert worden sind die
panzer die aus tschechien geliefert
ihrem kampf gegen diesen aggressor zu
wurden wurden hinter der weitergabe
unterstützen gegen putin aber eben nicht
klausel von deutschland genehmigt und im
mit schweren waffen stimmt denn der
eindruck dass die bundesregierung zu
zögerlich ist andere länder tun mehr
übrigen wurde auch ersatz zugesichert
liefern konkret liefern waffen andere
also insofern ist deutschland dort schon
tätig gewesen wir haben ab wir raketen
regierungschefs sind auch in die ukraine
und vieles andere geliefert und wir
gereist das ist alles bei der
arbeiten weiterhin auch der lian der
bundesregierung nicht der fall ist soll
liste der waffen die die ukraine genannt
jetzt mehr geld geben in einer neuen
hat die sie benötigt und werden für
runde eine milliarde euro aber man hat
alles versuchen um lieferungen auch
schon das gefühl und die kritik kommt ja
möglich zu machen die bundeswehr ist aus
nicht nur von der opposition nicht nur
eigenen beständen nicht mehr lieferfähig
von anderen eu-staaten nicht nur aus der
aber es gibt andere möglichkeiten die
ukraine sondern auch von der eigenen
ukraine mit waffen zu versorgen
koalition die grünen und die fdp man hat
welche möglichkeiten werden dass das ist
das gefühl der bundeskanzler ist
sowohl die industrie als auch eben
zögerlich wie gesagt die panzer die
andere partner länder die über vor allem
geliefert worden sind aus tschechien
in der ukraine einsatzfähige waffen
sind mit mit deutscher genehmigung
geliefert worden das war notwendig weil
sie aus nva beständen standen und wir
haben diese lieferung auch insofern
[Musik]